what we have here are two bits of card
on the bottom of it
i'm going to ask you to write down two
different numbers there can be any
numbers at all they've just got to be
different and i've actually called them
for you
already a and b
but they're two different numbers they
could be it could be a million it could
be ten yeah it could be point zero zero
one it could be a half it could be pi or
e or anything like that just two numbers
and you're gonna put them face down and
you can't have imaginary numbers they've
got to be
say
real numbers what i'm going to do
i'm going to
just decide to overturn one of them so
this one here say
and i'm going to tell you with more than
50
chance of me being correct
whether this one is bigger the upturned
one is bigger than the one that's face
down
now you would have thought that
this would be absolutely impossible
because surely
you know i only have a 50 50 chance i've
got there's two numbers here one's
bigger than the other and i've got 50 50
chance of picking each one
you know we
you know obviously we put a and b but
they're gonna have two different values
so it depends what you've put as a and b
it depends which one i chance it's just
50 50.
um but there is a fantastically
ingenious way that puts the odds in my
favor that means
i will win this game over half the time
what i'm gonna do and the way that this
works is that i myself i'm going to
generate another number completely
randomly and i've done one already and
i'm going to call it k
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to look at the number that's been
revealed
a
if the number that's been revealed is
bigger than my random number i'm going
to say a is the biggest number
if
a is smaller
than k the random number i'm going to
say no no
this one here the one that's unrevealed
the hidden number is the biggest number
and just by doing this
i can guarantee that statistically my
odds are much well are better than 50
50. so it's more likely than not that i
will be correct in determining whether
the revealed or the hidden card which
one is bigger k is a randomly generated
number the mathematical small print so
to speak is that i need to take it from
a distribution
that covers all the numbers so for
example the normal distribution um you
know you can set the uh the mean and the
standard deviation it just needs to come
and you can get this on the internet i
just need to generate a number which
could possibly be there is a chance no
matter how small of it being any number
and we can do this to five so anyway
this is k
if we were playing this game for real
alex how would you have generated k
would you have gone over to your
computer yeah i would have gone over to
computer i would have googled random
number generator normal distribution i
would have put the mean the standard
deviation and i would have got something
and because you know we're humans we're
you know you could be clever and clever
and say this is going to be a google
this is going to be a google times of
google most people are going to say
this is number between one and a hundred
this is probably a number between one
and a hundred and so i would put with my
um
you know the mean would be 50 and the
you know
standard deviation 20 or something like
that
so why does this work
now let's consider values of k
and in fact what i'm going to do i'm
going to reveal this a and b there are
three different
possible scenarios
either k
is less than both a and b
or k
is bigger than both a and b
or i have managed to get k i've hit the
spot it's between a and b or it could be
like that because we don't know which
one's bigger basically k is in is in
between
and so what i'm going to show now
this is dan is that if k
is
lower
as i said i'm gonna choose a always i
stick with a
and because
we know that both of these numbers are
bigger than k so because k is lower it's
still a 50 50 chance if k is bigger i
flip so in both cases where my number k
that's randomly generated is either less
than both of a and b or bigger than both
of a and b
then the odds are still 50 50.
when it makes a difference is just say
that k is in between a and b because if
k is in between a and b
i always win i always know which is
biggest so if i say a
is biggest then i know i'm right because
k has to be less than a we know that k
is in between so i'm right but if a is
less than k
we know that k is in between n b so i
would be choosing b and i would also be
right because b is bigger than a so just
by this random generation of a number
that has absolutely nothing to do with
the numbers that you chosen you wrote
here if it so happens that this number k
is in between these two numbers both
scenarios
i am correct
alex it feels like
the bigger the gap between a and b that
i left when i wrote down the numbers to
start with
the greater i was increasing your
chances correct so if you knew that i
was doing this
you could try and make it as difficult
as possible for me to get the edge by
choosing an a and a b that are really
really close together but so
long as
i'm choosing from a distribution where
all numbers are game there's a slight
chance of choosing any number
i have the edge i always have the edge
obviously if you choose
big numbers you know if you were to
choose minus a thousand and plus a
thousand
i would pretty much win every time
so yeah the larger the gap
the easier you know it's like the the
wider the goal
to use a football metaphor the wider the
goal
i mean i said i haven't actually done
this as an experiment but i imagine if i
was to tell you put two numbers down
you're probably gonna say something like
i don't know 12 and 30.
you know that's kind of quite a
reasonable thing that you're going to do
most people would probably choose not a
digit that seems a bit too small but in
the hundreds that's just like too
complicated you probably do something
between say 10 and 50.
so
if i'm
you know if i'm
putting my distribution so that it's
heavily picking up those numbers between
50 i'd say that you play this game 100
times maybe there's someone who actually
wants to run the simulations i i wager
that it would actually be
you'd be winning
not just more than 50 but a significant
amount more than 50 of the time i
guarantee you one thing else
i guarantee you there will be number
five viewers who run this simulation i
can't wait i can't wait
even if i'm proved wrong